good morning Hank it's Wednesday as you
can tell from the great speckled wall
behind me I'm in an airport I also had a
colonoscopy yesterday and for lack of a
better word I'm still feeling kind of
crappy so good news people who haven't
yet read the first six chapters of The
Great Gatsby you have an extension until
Monday okay hold on I got to get on a
plane and now I'm at Hogwarts I think
there are a lot of nerdfighters
downstairs at leakycon 2011 right now
and I feel kind of bad because they all
want to take pictures and I want to take
pictures too but I have this crippling
social anxiety disorder that makes it
impossible for me to do that kind of
thing or to hug strangers or whatever
and I feel Duchess Baha feel guilty in
other news Hank you know that album
you've been working on for a year and a
half Ellen Hardcastle which you named
after a nerdfighter who want a project
for awesome raffle anyway Hank I don't
know when it comes out but I'm really
excited
hi so Ellen Hardcastle is out today yes
it is it's available now and I've got a
big box of them downstairs that I have
not looked at yet congratulations it has
awesome cover art what you're looking at
now instead of Hanks face sorry Hanks
face so yesterday we were talking about
how you know I'm signing every
pre-ordered copy of The Fault in Our
Stars I thought that wasn't enough so
I've decided that instead of doing that
for Ellen Hardcastle I am going to let
you say whatever you want me to say in a
video you are such a brother like I have
a good idea and if you have to have a
better idea every person who buys a
physical copy of Ellen Hardcastle you
are going to be able to send me a 10
word script for a video and I'm going to
film that video and then put it onto
YouTube sunfare I was going to make
thousands of there are rules like it
cannot be profaned it has to be in
English and it has to make sense oh look
what those people are doing is something
I would never do so if you want your own
blood brothers video with Hank green
saying ten words of your choosing as
long as they're not profane and they
make sense you can just buy a copy of
Ellen Hardcastle and then you'll get an
email with instructions about how to
proceed
dftba slash Ellen Hardcastle or possibly
not Hardcastle
I don't know how awesome is it that you
named that album after a nerdfighter who
donated the project for awesome and her
name happened to be Owen Hardcastle
anything else there are good songs on
Ellen Hardcastle
all right the music
good it's good it has such hits as
Phineas Gage and strange charm the best
song ever written about quarks
admittedly low bar but it exceeds it by
a lot other hits include shake a booty
which you probably haven't heard yet but
it's one of my favorite songs ever and
there's lots of songs that you haven't
heard and there's other song Kathryn
what are the other songs we had Kathryn
hiding in the bathroom Fermi paradox
paradox the best song ever written about
the Fermi paradox it's true it's true
don't know I completely agree I mean you
dominate you know little-known
scientific phenomena songs about I want
that to be on my next Hank green t-shirt
Hank green dominating we don't know in
scientific phenomena comma songs about I
have to go to rehearsal now dftba
Hank I will see you as soon as I turn
off this video a pork is a fundamental
constituent of matter observed in 1968
the people acetic scattered we found
that protons aren't as simple as we
thought we thought they were solid
particles but they are not protons in
fact are made up of three separate
pieces it just gets more confusing as
our knowledge
Risa's but that is what at work is it's
a piece of a proton and they also make
up other things including da new
down strange
if you don't know water
toms and bosons
everything that you see
with this